[Applause]
the possessed take over the streets of
Phuket
now in the State of Trance the impaling
begins the risks are great the spike
could induce uncontrollable bleeding
nerve damage could occur
the wounds will become easily infected
and there will be permanent scarring
but it would take a far braver man to
defy the will of the gods to stop now
is unthinkable
[Music]
scores of spirit mediums pour out of the
shrine
they will march to the sea and back a
distance of 5 miles with temperatures in
the 90s
[Music]
the people of Phuket lined the streets
to witness their suffering suffering
they endure on behalf of the whole
community in gratitude
shop owners make their own offerings to
the gods while the spirit mediums are
entrusted to expel the ills of the
island the other residents also play
their part to purify their bodies and
their minds they are all on a strict
vegetarian diet throughout the festival
who can't be bought for Chavan kicking
gay people in trances or possessed by
God's good spirits they will then go to
greet all the people of Phuket they've
been on the vegetarian diet people set
up tables in front of the houses with
offerings to all these gods they start
by and bless all these people to be
happy and to have a long life
among those carrying weapons is go Gao
an hour into the journey he breaks into
a frenzied attack on himself
he bleeds heavily and there is still a
long way to go a shop owner makes an
offering to go gal to acknowledge that
he has taken on the pain and suffering
of the entire community minutes later
another man begins slicing his own
tongue with an axe
despite this grotesque spectacle the
atmosphere is festive it's a celebration
really and so that seems like a paradox
you have the pain but you have the
celebration as well but that's not
uncommon there are lots of rituals
around the world that combine pain and
danger with celebration singing joy and
so forth the objects chosen by the
scapegoats for piercing are symbolic of
the weapons held by these Chinese idols
the gods are warlike in appearance the
masochists become their soldiers however
strict tradition is making way for what
is now a competition of self-mutilation
these soldiers of the gods now use tree
branches chair legs mom brows
they compete for favor among the gods by
stretching the limits of their own flesh
it's a dangerous game that mr. ho does
not approve off
the only right object is the pointed rod
but some of the followers want to show
off that they are soldiers of the gods I
don't think it's right
I want to ban piercings with those
unusual objects
[Applause]